so many people think that iodine is only
good for the thyroid but it actually
extends beyond that even though the
thyroid gets the lion's share of iodine
but it's also concentrated in the
salivary glands okay why because iodine
is antimicrobial antibacterial antiviral
antiparasite so it can help you there
it's also in the cerebral spinal fluid
which is a fluid around the brain and
the brain itself and that is why in a
growing child it's important to have
iodine because if that child is
deficient it could affect the learning
ability the IQ and the general
intelligence it's in the stomach it's
also in the breast tissue and the ovary
tissue mainly to help regulate and
buffer excessive amounts of estrogen now
it doesn't give you more estrogen what
it does is it balances it out a bit it
will lower the bad and increase the good
so it's really good for things like
fibrocystic breast or cysts in the
ovaries which basically is an estrogen
dominant situation and iodine just
brings it down to balance it out it's
also in the eye and in the inner ear if
pregnant female is deficient in iodine
the child could come out with hearing
issues as well so it buffers estrogen
it's great for the immune system really
good for sinus it's an anti mucus
mineral good to improve ADHD it's really
essential for fertility as well as IQ
okay the RDAs which is the recommended
amount would be a hundred and 50
micrograms not milligrams with
micrograms but the most concentrated
source would be from seek help because
it concentrates the iodine in the
seawater and make sure if you're doing
sea kelp it's a high quality sea kelp
one capsule of seek help would give you
about 150 or even a little more than
that micrograms to give you the daily
amount alright thanks for watching
hey if you haven't already subscribed
press the button below and I will keep
you in the know hey that rhymes